y à juliaca sélectionné trois moments
cultes pour lui télé voilà alors
stationné cioni d'abord le théâtre les
dérapages de benoît poelvoorde en
plateau paraît que ça c'est non mais
c'est une séquence moi je la revois il
en avoir 200 fois je crois qu'il est
donc invitée dans un talk show on passe
des extraits télé ils ont annulé à ce
grand ouais ouais et on lui passe un
extrait d'une vieille émission qui l'ont
s'être de perdus de vue
c'est parce que perdu de vue c'était
avant pradel ya bellemare qu'il a fait
est que la barbe
ouais et bellemare permet un homme de
retrouver son fils et poelvoorde
commence à baisser
c'est magnifique a choisi trois
meilleurs et la joie de vous présenter
monsieur certains fils que vous allez
lui avec 2 10
le voici
[Applaudissements]
et il est remboursé
non pas la barbe de l'homme sacré nom de
dieu qu'est ce que c'est que c'est du
bon jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après ils passent dans un truc ça dure
dix minutes
màj junior au numéro 2 a choisi aussi un
truc de qui veut gagner des millions
mais pas en france ouais alors ça c'est
pas franchement marrant mais c'est juste
dément le mec doc est sur le point de
gagner le million de dollars
l appel et il appelle son père mais
d'une décontraction lui disant je
t'appelle pour te dire qu'on est
maintenant à la tête tous les deux d'un
million de dollars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ses compatriotes ulien parce que je sais
qu'après on va passer à thé ex traiter
avec toi et je me rappelle d'un fou rire
coup d'arrêt ce mec a gagné 1 million a
perdu après à motus
ça c'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas les
images je suis là il arrive à quelle
heure le robot il en moelleux le vol ait
honte et rue on a le droit il fait ce
qu'il veut et on numéro tatoué à
l'antenne un choix en dire des drôles 1
alors tu as choisis tu as choisi un truc
avec deux icônes coluche et belmondo et
ya boujenah au cimic intervient pas trop
il se pourrait par exemple bourg et
voilà ils sont à la au lancement du
disque de la santé oms et de sotomayor
de jean paul belmondo qui joue avec lui
d'un dans un de ses films d'ailleurs
donc il a fait venir tous ses copains et
là la journaliste vient leur poser des
questions sauf que vient la fin du repas
ben ils ont picoler pendant tout le
repas et les deux vont lui répondre bien
éméché regard est énorme pourquoi ce
soir là vous en tous sens
qu'est-ce qui est là pourquoi ce soir
qu'est ce qu'on a pour sa non je
commence c'est la fin du dîner là vous
êtes là pourquoi ce soir la sortie du
disque de carlos sotto mayor et voulait
mais écouter ce disque encore un ballon
on a invité bois sans pour l'instant on
a écouté le dîner ça a été un peu à
temps et bada mais qui est là ça c'est
le même c'est le même mais en petit à
régler et je suis poli quand moi j'ai vu
le clic
il n'a pas regretté t il va repasser
je laissais déloyale pour les autres
chanteuses calais c'est déloyal c'est
trop bon
comprenez où j'arrive à vous faire rire
et piccoli je vais vous faire rire tous
les matins blêmes airways ba c'est
pourquoi le sport à toute la famille de
charles gérard voilà parce qu'il ya une
semaine c'était vraiment le complice le
meilleur pote de bébelles il se
lâchaient pas tous les deux et je pense
très très fort à jean-paul je fais des
normes bisous